[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect yo what's up guys I am
Thomas doola whatever you want to call
me I'm here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys what's up guys dope as
usual podcast you can talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything you between today is a very
special episode we're going to jump
right into it this is the fluffy episode
Gabriel glaus thank you for being here
thank you why do I feel like drugs
should lead the thing cuz usually a lot
of those things stem from from that from
no what it was was a we thought we can't
lead with it you know what I mean cuz
like we're in trouble we get we're in
trouble enough for talking so I figure
let's just talk about life and then
we'll work into the drugs like life or
just change you know it's all about
titles nowadays you always just got to
change the name of it so it doesn't
sound as abrasive or as you know yeah
you it's life
prescriptions RX and accomplishments
that's hilarious that's not even a bad
idea for real we put on a like life
self-medicating and yeah yeah exactly
healing healing problem cuz drugs always
sounded harsh no matter how you say it
it just like drugs if it's legal like
drugs yeah it
does even if it's legal yeah totally not
a bad idea at all actually um so real
quick I want to uh or make it cute extra
cute like you know like life puffy wuffy
make it sound stupid cute puffy wuffy
yeah puffy wuffy like who's going to get
like offended or or get scared of of
cute words that might stop us from
getting interested so bad we're we're
just here having a little puffy wuffy
and uh talking about life and the
pursuit of happiness it's not a bad idea
Marty how you just come in here and
rework our whole business sorry about
that it's okay no we need help no no but
thank you for having me sorry I'm not
here trying to take over your show fine
thank you for being here uh I I want to
get started um you're from California
obviously yes and I want to know have
you ever I'm from mered a little baby
town you probably know have you ever
played there I've played everywhere you
have in California especially yeah all
the small towns the vielas the delos the
freaking you know all the way up North
all the way down you know
Broly I don't even know what that see is
yeah exactly and a fireball yeah he like
like is he making some of these
up um so that was a question me Marty
were thinking what's your favorite
section of Cali without excluding
yourself from other places is there a
place you go like I can't wait to be in
San Francisco I can't wait to go to
reading is there a place in California
you just like to be and perform uh I
love performing in San Jose San Jose's
always been a lot of fun uh Oxnard is
always a lot of fun by Ventura right
yeah yeah uh San Francisco not so much
just cuz it's um I don't know if it's
the hills or everyone pumps up San
Francisco but man that city's been going
through a lot and every day they're in
the news and I'm like why is real estate
still so high you know I think they're
trying to get everybody out there they
can't afford it and go hey all the rich
people live over there something's going
on I was just there the other day and it
shocked me look like Skid Row out here
yeah wasn't fun so uh it's it's changed
a lot it used to be one of my favorite
places to perform and don't get me wrong
we you know it's always good shows and
stuff like that it's just you know as
far as an area you want to enjoy and be
around you know if I'm there for the
weekend I'd like to go out and walk
around and I want to feel safe
exactly you want to feel safe not go
Uber to Uber and door to door yeah
that's how I felt she uh my wife did the
marathon out there and the whole time
I'm thinking you're running through San
Francisco I don't want to run by you
just protect you because I'm fat but I
was thinking like dude what do I do
here's some mace They Carried They
Carried
stuff I don't know just I just want to
get I don't know how we got into that
yeah this whole State's going through
something right now they are they are
but want to talk about something else
you did Stadium fluffy your special you
did yeah brought it back to LA I love it
to but he was he was tell spending too
much time talking about San Francisco
it's uh there's nothing else to talk
about we did a good hour on how shitty
San Francisco yeah we did a couple week
ago yeah we did you sold out the stadium
pretty cool huh for a comedian right
pretty cool yeah Dodger Stadium it was
not an easy feat uh there was a lot of a
big team of people involved in that and
a lot of thinking outside the box to
promote it to get it to where we got it
MH was it multiple shows uh we had two
nights so it was a Friday Saturday you
had to do it twice yes which was good
because you always want like for me
anytime I tape a special I always want
to do two shows I never do live I never
do live because you can you can never
predict just something you know like
whether it's a a Heckler that won't let
up or maybe there's an issue with the
building maybe there's a flickering
light maybe the sound doesn't hit the
way it should and this way you always
record too and if anything happens or
you need a little splice you can you can
work the magic have you had a Heckler
during a special uh I've had people yell
stuff out yeah thinking that oh it's
going to make it to the special I'm like
dude this isn't live if it was live then
maybe you can get your 10 seconds of
Fame but no that's why never live the
only time that's ever happened was was
it Delirious or raw I love you shut up
[__] you remember that something like
that that's what it was like the one
person that ever made the special was
that lady and she got [__] on by it was
Charlie Murphy that yelled that out by
the way watch the little thing behind it
and even and even then it still wasn't
live mhm
I didn't think about that they obviously
just keep that in like for example I
know like in this last uh Netflix run
Chris Rock did his live which was
awesome because they got a lot of hype
and and he's a pro and he you know did
what he did but he did have a little
flub in there and he caught himself oh
like messed up your own words yeah in
the in the thing and then uh but now
when you watch it on the uh replay they
fixed it but live man live it's like I
don't want to mess up and and by mess up
you mean like forget your act forget
yeah or just you know say something
that's gonna like you know just derail
the show so I'm trying to put myself in
the brain of that like what do you mess
up like you made it but I get what
you're saying like the point is always
two shows so we were there Friday and
Saturday and uh yeah and good thing too
cuz I felt like the first show I was
kind of still adjusting to performing in
in a in a venue that big and then the
second night I was a lot more
comfortable MH now I have a long history
working with comedians behind the scenes
and like helping them promote their
shows and stuff like that I've never
never seen an act travel as much as you
do you know I've heard you say like my
mom told me we got 365 days in the year
we're going to work all of them why not
let work yeah that's how we are too but
you did you guys see the IG post I did
yesterday yeah the flight map yeah
that's the one he just showed me yeah
I'm afraid of flying how do you manage
what material you're doing on stage
versus what material is going to be
coming up for the next Netflix special
when you're on the road so much well I'm
always playing I'm always playing so
it's like I'll just throw material out
there and just have fun fun with it so
trying to stick to one set I'll get
bored I'll get bored and then it'll feel
like work I would rather dig a hole and
try to get out of that hole so it's kind
of like a challenge it's like it's a
game to see can I can I intentionally
mess up my set and see if I can pull
myself out of it so it's a really good
exercise it's funny a big guy talking
about exercise I know I got to CH I got
to change the
verbage how I get my rep I want to make
sure I'm happy wappy yeah
no don't don't worry be fluffy how many
tour dates are you doing uh well we're
God the next couple years it's just
going to be there yeah the next couple
years is going to have that name uh so
it's got to be at
least about between 350 and 400 dates
insan you know and then so we're still
going to Europe we're going to Australia
uh I know that the Middle East is
calling we got to we've got to make up
some dates over there and theaters or
just Arenas uh you know what it's mostly
Arenas but there are some places where
I'm I'm you know I'm not selling as many
tickets so it doesn't make sense to go
into an arena you know you would just go
into a theater how do you keep from
being exhausted just I'm always tired
man I'm always tired okay I slept good
just for this interview cuz people just
love your energy so much it's got to be
so much to keep that up it is it is a
lot and at the end of the night once I
get off the stage it's like you know the
dude gets unplugged you know what I mean
and so I want up on my bus and people
think oh it's a party after I'm like I'm
47 not 27 so it's it's a little bit
different and I just want to lay down
and kiss my dogs and like all right it
was it was good you've been doing this
we reflect I look at the tour manager
did you order something to eat cool
where is it yeah just a little hang out
but yeah I'm I'm once I'm off the stage
I'm sitting down on a couch or you know
I get to lay down and you know call it a
day but I do I do save my energy for the
stage did it take a long time to like
learn like okay I need to I need to
manage this cuz no it just with age dude
cuz in the beginning I had all the
energy in the world I can you stay up
all night and it wasn't even a uh uh
what was the word that we used it wasn't
a prescription that kept me up all night
it was it was just youth it was just
youth I was you know I could drink and
then uh be hung over and then get over
my hangover by 8: a.m. and catch a
flight whereas now I drink and I'm I'm
hurting for two days isn't that weird
yeah I just drank the other night with
this guy he has no effect it was his
birthday the other day has no effect of
alcohol on this guy yeah I felt it all I
realized it I'm like damn I'm not shots
are shots are bouncing off me literally
I I I feel you now I'm like Oh my
backs that's how I wake up like ah you
know can't drink like I used to drink
fifths and have fun no so there was no
uh uh preparing as much as it was
reacting like I can't do this or I can't
do that I got to slow down on this but
as far as the touring goes it's like you
know that's it's what I do that's all
I've done for the last 20 some odd years
now D so go go go how long were you
working on the last special before you
filmed it let's see the last special I
want to say about a year and a half two
years oh okay on the road cuz that's
different than most comedians are doing
like local shows they go on the road
like every once in a while on the
weekend that's just it's different to be
going out working your material at
Arenas and that's always uh challenging
to work out new material at an arena
show because man people pay top dollar
at an arena show and you want the best
experience you don't want a dude that's
up there practicing you know R running
stuff by you so it's very uh that part
gets a little tricky cuz I got to make
sure that I get I can sneak in a new bit
here and there and test the waters and
most of the time people can't you know
it's if if I feel good about the bit
it's it's probably going to work out but
uh it nothing beats being in a comedy
club and just people know like oh man
this is raw right here like all right
here we go and I did that for the first
six months of this year I did nothing
but comedy clubs oh man after Dodger
Stadium my agent and manager wanted me
to just continue the arena run and I'm
I'm like you know I need to fall in love
with this cuz I just I became a hoe it
was all about the money at that point
it's like it's just just a machine and I
wasn't enjoying it and so I had to pump
the brakes and I said let me go back to
clubs cuz at clubs every night when I
went up on stage I said you know what my
favorite part is about being here
tonight is knowing I don't have to be
here I'm I want to be here and I want to
have fun and I want to make sure you
guys have fun I go this is not money you
know don't get me wrong of course I get
paid for it but I could be somewhere
else killing it but I want I want to be
in a club and I want to I want to just
enjoy that stage and just the realness
of it was there a point in your career
that was like defining in terms of
taking that next level from the clubs
and the theaters to like okay I'm
basically just doing Arenas now was
there something that caused that or was
it a slow thing that just kind of
occurred I think there's been a lot of
steps you know there's not one thing in
particular that made that next thing
there's always like well this led to
this and this led to this and so it's
always been steps and all these
different Milestones um definitely uh in
the beginning it was you know the help
of Comedy Central uh there was a
television show back in the day called
kokos it was on galavision on the
Spanish Network it was the weirdest
thing it's like English comedy on a
Spanish network but because that Spanish
Network didn't have a lot of um a lot of
content they would constantly replay the
comedy and so normally like you would
only get maybe one or two plays on like
let's say comedy Center in the course of
a week or even a month whereas on
gvision they were running my you you you
would just stumble onto my set if you
were clicking through the channel 13 cuz
they played it like three four times a
day yeah and it was like insane it's
like the gvision was the fluffy Network
you know what I mean it was just like
okay yeah there we go and then they were
running commercials cuz they had a tour
and I was part of the tour so of course
they put my face on the thing and so in
between soccer and all everything it was
just constantly hitting hitting hitting
plus Comedy Central so that took me to
the next level and then there was you
know uh the comedy special the one hour
specials that I started putting out and
then that put me in a different place
and then I got an offer to do a movie an
actual standup movie called The Fluffy
Movie and I said well if we're going to
go big let's give it a shot and so once
we played in an arena then it was like
okay we can do Arenas and then that was
the all right well let's go from there
and then the next uh every special after
that has been an arena or or uh
Stadium sorry that sounds it almost
sounds like I'm going to make some [__]
up real quick I'm going to play do
Stadium doesn't even sound real it
doesn't it doesn't and and and when
people ask me did you ever think you
could do something like that no no I
just wanted to pay my rent go to Costco
and freaking eat hot $150 hot dogs man
that's I still like doing that or those
Circle turkey things with the Tor the
chicken bake no no the they sell in the
whole the in the back they're like
little sandwich circles I just this my
favorite thing from Costco oh the the
rap the turkey wrap and they cut in
little pieces so I don't feel as fat
eating all of them cuz there was a
version of you 25 years ago maybe
sitting at a kiosk working for a phone
company right as we talk about I look
like you oh you want to bring that up I
look like you I get it every day I was
clean shav I had hair you see that look
turn around real quick every day I get
this I get it every day they go hey
little fluffy and I go I get it fool I
cuz I tell that's all I do on my I tell
stories you know I tell hell stories and
everybody always tells me like you're
not fat you're just full of stories yeah
you're me at
28 yeah is that how old are you 33 okay
yeah yeah pretty much the same man I got
to be honest and then my wife says like
well he's you on vacation like yeah I do
got to wear some more fun shirts I still
have that shirt but I don't have that
hair it's okay yeah know it was a good
run it was a good run it last it it was
a good run yo push tre's floral shirt
would go
crazy yeah I wear floral shirts I went
to the islands once and I put it on and
felt like I feel gross
gr wear buttons like I feel I wear
t-shirts every day of my life I don't
know you know what I'm saying but yes I
get it every day especially on Tik Tok I
I don't know if you ever look at your
own stuff but I'm that guy that's tagged
50,000 times funny every day every day
man every day and when I watch your
specials and I'm like these are just
amazing Stories like it's just it's
captivating and that's why I watch it
till the end and that's how I think
that's why your YouTube
channel it can you can just press play
and be gone for 5 hours and it will just
you'll never have to change it there's
always stories there's always something
to lead you somewhere else and then you
see like oh that's from 10 years ago oh
this is from yesterday I I love the
channel man Channel's good the Channel's
great and I think that's why like you
were saying it was the fluffy Network on
channel 13 but YouTube is kind of like
that too very true you know it just
circulates I don't even have to be
logged in I would and you know what I
wish I was a lot more engaged on YouTube
I feel like that's the one that like you
know I've always relied on other people
to create content based on stuff that
I've put out there and then put put it
on upload it I don't even I don't even
have my login for for YouTube it's like
there's if you were going doing
premieres and in the live chat people
would go insane you know that live chat
Premiere I've never done it we do it
every episode for every video ever and
it's the most fun people will lose their
mind if you win in there and goes hey
guys I'm watching with you for the first
time everybody watching the premiere
together together you could talk to
people it is the most fun I feel like
that back in my day we had a VHS and
just no that's me too that's me too what
was it what did I just learn oh yes last
episode I don't know how to use a
computer it's okay get it I can use
emails he's my editor I'm still trying
to learn how to freaking paste the the
videos together to make them you know
like I'm always working on on trying to
make the videos look cool really all the
content you put out you're not a whiz
with the editing and stuff no I wish I
was I mean you know the creating of the
content's one thing but like adding the
subtitles or putting the the the the the
you know sometimes the there's movement
or just little little features uh little
Sparkle here and there whatever I don't
know I don't know how to how to do any
of that and I actually I need I need
somebody to help me so Reach Out reach
out put in your put in your application
this got flooded right now yeah no
seriously cuz I I have the content I
just don't have the editing skills and I
I lack that and I need help with that
yeah and and but I don't want to have to
send it off somewhere to some guy and
some guy need to sit next to you go you
know what that's funny it needs to be
yeah exactly it need to be somebody like
all right cool yeah just do this give me
your phone I'll knock this out order me
two tacos right now I'll knock it out
real quick dude where it working for
this oh man that'd be so fun an editor
working there having fun it's not even a
job at that point I feel do you like
vlogging uh vlogging is remind me what
that is I feel like it's there's writing
you're you're documenting a situation
right you're just filming yourself in
your day and that's all it is if you
have a camera guy following you that is
a vlog and that just like the stories
though like aren't you just doing store
but vlogging is just a whole a whole P
one whole video like say it's 10 minutes
and you went to go get food with your
friend and you guys film the entire
thing that's it could be that that
sounds more like evidence that doesn't
sound that sounds like I'm going to show
this to your doctor dude look being an
[__] look at let me show you sounds
like evidence yeah no but that it's it'd
be fun I mean you have a fan base that
would love to see hey what' you do
Tuesday and great so the the then that's
the part that I need to help with where
it's like someone to just say hey dude
it' be really quick and easy if we just
knock this out and I'm like okay but
it's like it's become work and that's
the part I hate and so with a lot of
things that I I do in my career there's
things that I can handle that are like I
want to be Hands-On responsible for and
certain things where it's like man you
know let me have someone else who who's
more um who has the skill set and the
patience and the time to to knock that
out because even if it's just a floating
caption like I can't do that yeah you do
it so and it's hard to say it's hard to
say you can't do things cuz then people
you know like oh is he weak or is he
stupid well that's just I'm just busy
there's only so many hours yeah there's
only so many hours in a day but I do
have visions and ideas it's just I don't
have C skill sets yeah yeah that's what
me that's what me and him works so well
he's a master editor I'm like hey you
know be funny that and then we get it we
got it done it's the best thing to do um
so when's your next date when's your
next uh tomorrow where I have this week
watch this this week I have five shows
in five states so I know I'm going to be
I know and I just had a show uh Sunday
at the Orange County the what Pacific
Amphitheater mhm so I had a show there
and then yesterday and today which you
came to see you and then I got to go see
the dentist yeah well thank you for
being
here thank you thank you so this week
though I have uh let's see watch
Nebraska South Dakota
Colorado uh Connecticut and Atlantic
City so I have I have five shows this
week you're a sad
when did you get over the fear of flying
or did you even have it I've never had a
fear of flying I only get scared
whenever the turbulence is next level
and that's only happened twice in 20
some odd years and then I had that
flight that almost you know we almost
had laboma part two last month the day
I'm like I don't want to be Frankie or
Richie Val afraid of flight private
private flight man I mean and and
usually when the when there's an issue
with the planes nine out of 10 times
it's a smaller plane that has the you
know the issue scar me man so what
happened you guys were taking off right
uh well the plane overshot the runway
200 yard they said that the reverse
thrusters didn't kick in but I'm still
wondering was texting oh [__] I'm like I
didn't feel breaks I didn't feel nothing
nobody yelled out hold on nothing it was
just like 200 yards is a distance yeah
and so now we're in a field we wound up
in a field and the planes just covered
with grass and dirt there's cows in the
I'm surprised we didn't hit a cow that
would have been crazy if we cow kind of
awesome well I'm I'm glad the issue
happened on the ground yeah oh but but
we did hit really bad turbulence in the
sky and I think that had something to do
with it but and my fault for not wearing
a seat belt but it was a private plane
why you know do jumping Jackson a
private plane whatever whatever but when
we came in it's like I felt it we were
just going way too fast and uh yeah it
looked like the opening scene from the
TV show Lost just I only seen the
opening scene just the you know the
planes in in a field and they're like oh
wow we're out here were you solo no I
was with uh you know with my guys so
Martin was on the on the plane my buddy
Matt our uh you know our tour manager
and our our video uh audio guy Victor so
it's a small group we were dude it was
scary we were this close to coming out
as gay to each other we were just we
were going to have we were going to have
that some spill
moments some side [__] we're just going
to yeah we were about to freaking all
the all the secrets are going to come
out in that last couple seconds cuz as
soon as we hit the dirt the plane was
just and we're just waiting
for the plane to do that you know was it
just slow motion like you could you just
took forever for it to happen it it felt
like it was forever even though it was
it was quick um but yeah watching grass
and dirt hit the window that looked
crazy oh no that look crazy and then you
see the plane after and the plane just
looks like you just need to pressure
wash that
sucker I have to fight next week I hate
flying so much I I wish I had your how
long till you got back on the private
jet after that we were on a PL playing
the next day so uh after we got picked
up uh there was a like the fire
department showed up they have a a fire
department at the airport and so they
were there and checking us all out
making sure we were good and then uh we
had to go to the hotel and we got a bite
to eat and then I get a phone call from
TMZ and uh I thought that was nice that
I got the call Direct and and they just
do it yeah and they're like are you okay
how are you I'm like I'm first thing
they asked yes which I thought was
awesome cool it wasn't about you know so
tell us what happened it you know it was
nice I got a call straight from Harvey
and Harvey was just like hey man you
okay you good I'm like yeah dude thank
you you know it's like wow it's crazy
yeah that's how you know it's some [__]
when they start calling you that's you
good yeah that's but I did appreciate
the fact that it was Harvey that called
me and the first thing he said was are
you okay MH and I'm like wow okay that's
a good A good measure measure of like oh
that guy's nice nice to everyone they
TMZ called you to say are you good you
know what I mean that should show like
I'm a nice person we're your window
right now and then it was like all right
who [__] up okay all right was it your
personal pil oh wait can we cuss yeah
say whatever you want okay I wasn't sure
you're good you're good I was like
you're fine you're fine was it a p a
random pilot or is it like your pilot no
it was our regular Pilots that we had
and so uh I have not seen him
since uh don't know what happened none
of the new pilots want to talk about the
old pilot it's kind of like a it's like
a relationship like yeah hey don't bring
up Carmen man
we don't we don't talk about
Bruno yo hold on do you know someone
named Bruno what you just make that name
I was like I don't think I ever met a
name that's from a movie Bruno no it's
from a movie you don't talk about Bruno
movie I used to have a dog I used to
have a chihuahua named Bruno he was cute
but no I don't know an actual Bruno okay
just wanted to ask that's the first
movie reference that went over your head
it's a kids movie what's kids movie uh
God that is the first reference uh
Encanto oh the one I haven't seen
Encanto need to watch it some people say
it's Coco too see I haven't seen that
either Encanto Eno and Coco both really
good ones by the way if you want to I
isn't it the one where the family has
powers all right yeah I seen it I've
seen it never mind I I watched it with
Sophia never mind what's up guys Tak it
a moment from this awesome episode to
talk about one of our brand new sponsors
this is raw papers if you didn't know
raw papers is the official paper of the
dope as usual podcast first off shout
out to them for believing in the show
thank you very much so what you got to
do is go to your local head shop your
local smoke shop and get raw papers
there but if you go to the shop and you
notice it's not there tell them to reup
go buy more stuff go to hbi
International if you're a store and you
want to check out wholesale hemp
composite plastic Grinders yes they're
plastic but it's made from hemp kind of
like chich and Chong where the whole car
is made of weed same concept raw has so
much more than papers there's every
single smoking thing you can think of
when it comes to rolling they got up
next this is the first paper I fell in
love with this is what I rolled through
Instagram the very first 3 years was
KingSize Supremes and then as everyone
knows the cone these are gigantic boxes
of raw cones if you can't roll they have
rollers and they have cones so remember
go to rawthentic.com every single
product they have the information they
have everything if you want to donate
you want to do charity thank you so much
to raw papers for sponsoring the dope as
usual podcast back to the episode what
is your favorite three movies of all
time Back to the Future one two or three
Back to the Future one okay Back to the
Future one uh Coming to America nice
and I want to say Forest Gump wow nice
that's my favorite movie yeah that's one
of those movies where it doesn't matter
where it's at I could just start
watching it that fans I just let my son
watch it for the first time he's nine
was classic legendary yeah they were
this close to making a sequel oh good
thing they didn't it just hit at the bus
stop and a bunch of ladies like he's
rich just try to pick up on him like
he's just fishing that was the whole
movie I'm not a small man but I know
what a ATM is at the strip club yo we we
have a we have a Forest Gump probably
comes up 92% of these episodes I didn't
think it was going to come up today so
it's such an awesome film and it's like
one of those like oh man you just feel
good afterwards and it's like yeah and
the other ones are just you know the
comedies you know yeah I like sci-fi I
like the you know uh Back to the Future
and then I of course old school Eddie
Murphy with Coming to America such a fun
movie all the characters did you watch
part two I did I saw part two and um
right you know I I I unfortunately I was
trying to watch it through old eyes
that's what I did too and it just it
wasn't the same it felt like it was uh
almost forced a little forced yeah yeah
okay all right Coming to America is is
classic man I don't know how many times
I watched that Dam but part two is I
feel like they waited too much time to
make that movie years it's
like you're playing to a whole new group
of people you might as well have done a
remake o you're not wrong with that I
think Kevin hartt could have killed it
if they would have done a
remake yeah Kevin Hart comic I know he
talk I'm imagining him as I'm only
imagining him as the guy in the the
bathroom attendant oh my God that Kevin
Hart could have crushed that role the
little dude could have crushed it um
okay yes the man I met in the restroom
remember yeah oh he just met him in the
restroom just met him in the rest so
glow dude ah you know what we'll talk
about coming to America all day so let's
but yeah top three movies uh Coming to
America Back to the Future and Forest
Gump nice okay now on the same kind of
thing but more on the audio side when
you're traveling the globe and you know
is what are you mainly listening to is
it books podcast music YouTube uh well
I'm I'm on Spotify listening to just
music I like listening to uh uh I'm a
big classic rock guy so I like old
school you know classic rock and stuff
like that Aeros Smith Tom Petty Eagles
Eagles are my favorite group I yeah I I
got to see them in in concert many times
and I was like yeah and I got to see
them recently right before another one
of the bad members MH so more more music
like that every now and then uh old
school like OG country like the new
stuff like George uh GS back in the day
or freaking uh George Jones that's my
uncle's favorite old George Jones and
Tom Johnny Cash stuff yeah well Johnny
Cash and then why can't I think family
tradition God why can't I think of his
name oh my God that's why I'm not like a
hardcore uh no Junior the junor oh uh
Hank Williams Jr thank you yeah like you
say Hank Williams II third no you seen
him he's a punk rock artist it's thrash
metal and it's insane and it's crazy
because uh Hank Williams Jr would sing
about how his music wasn't like his
daddy's music and now and now number
three is definitely like not like his
daddy's music he looks like this he's a
punk rocker he's tatted and he's just
not for me but you know music's Music
Man and and it's just kind of wild to
see the three generations of that it's
pretty nut M I missed the Monday Night
Football song I don't like the new car
oh you read it or I don't if I like the
new one it doesn't hype me up like the
guy with the hat did you know um
speaking of other fun stuff what was it
like going to
WWE well
uh which time I mean I'm I'm the the
most recent WWE or just wrestling in
general that's my uh guilty pleasure
every year I make it a point to go to
WrestleMania uh every year if I'm going
to you know like the first time I got to
go I says you know what I've always
wanted to do this as a kid and now I'm
working my ass off and I never take time
off but I always you know uh block out
that week and and I go to the Hall of
Fame and I go to the you know now
wrestlemania's two nights where's the
Hall of Fame at they usually have it at
the arena that's near the stadium and so
you get to go see the Hall of Fame and
that's always cool cuz it's a nostalgic
you see all the old wrestlers from the
past getting inducted and everybody has
speeches and stories and I love all that
and then of course you go to the event
and then the event's the event man so
I've never been man it's it's a thing
once you go to one you're gonna be like
I get it I get it I'll I'll I'll be I'll
be there next year who's your favorite
three wrestlers if you're if you're a
real I mean any era favorite three
wrestlers uh Rey Mysterio
oh okay Rey Mysterio I'd have to go
um for sure Stone Cold and Ric Flair and
probably uh Stone St coold first then
Ric Flair second then Rey
Mysterio man I was 11 when Stone Cold
was really popping and he was the
coolest man on
earth I I I can say uh I've used his
bathroom I've I've gotten drunk with him
and I got a I I got a pedicure with
him that's some random like fun facts
those are fun facts I I blew up his
bathroom it's evolving got drunk with
him and we got pedicures we we done
random things too we shot like you know
crossbows and hung out and raced we
raced each other's uh like he had this
Camaro and I had a TransAm basically
like very much in the same vein and uh
yeah we raced it's pretty cool I know
even you're looking down as you start
going I'm about to race don't CL defa oh
yeah and in the beginning the first time
when we got the introduction we got
introduced through a a um a friend of
you know we both have a friend named uh
Diamond Dallas pige who was another
wrestler DDP helped me out with the some
weight loss in doing yoga and that's how
I met him and he calls me he's like bro
uh played your videos for Steve and I'm
like okay Steve who I think Steve is one
of his video guys that he has I'm like
okay Steve knows my [__] he goes no
Steve Austin I'm like Stone Cold he's
like yeah and he goes he wants to have
you on his podcast I'm like oh my God he
goes he goes he's going to call you from
a 310 area code I'm like all right next
thing I know I get the phone call and
it's him you know this a some [__] they
call fluffy I'm like I'm just like yeah
and then I could hear Diamond Dallas
Page in the background hey bro and I'm
like dude why didn't you just hand him
the phone why did
you you should just hand him hand him
the phone it would have been easier but
yeah then I went to his house it was
really cool wow really really cool and
hanging out and just talking and you
know there's so many similarities
between pro wrestling and comedy you
know uh it's you got to remember it's
it's a show and everything that goes
into a show that travels you know the
the time spent at the airports the
hotels the checking in the trying to get
your money dealing with promoters
dealing with promotion there's all kinds
of different things that are very
similar and you know of course you know
they got the good days the bad days and
things uh problems that that arise when
you travel you know whether it's at home
or you know uh substances or or getting
carried away with with with you know
everything that's going on there's a lot
of similarities which I think is why a
lot of wrestlers come to comedy shows
and a lot of comedians go to you know
wrestling events we just had Will Sasso
on here and he is a fanatic of WWE so he
played Stone Cold and on on
WWE yeah yeah we we saw his little thing
and then he got stone cold stunnered
which was kind of Epic I got suspended
in sixth grade for Stone Cold stuning
everyone I pile Drive someone once yeah
to the head to the ground yeah oh are
they okay they walked I think they're
good truck I broke someone's neck off
there there was no ambulance or nothing
but I yeah were you a kid though yeah I
was a kid I was a kid but dude yeah you
heard it don't freak
it and I'm
like and he's like oh you got me and I'm
like yes in hindsight oh man I could
have snapped that dude kill them yeah
you don't you don't Triple H pedigree
you don't DD well as a kid you didn't
know you're supposed to pull back or
you're supposed to make it look good no
man you you know on TV they try to kill
him and Y as a kid you're like yeah
that's why they started playing that
video do not try this at home at the
beginning at the beginning of Jack every
anything that you can copy they had to
cuz I was the one trying to do it did
you uh I mean I don't know if you did
but I used to do the uh I was in the
Jeff Hardy Matt Hardy area
so I used to try to Swan on bomb off of
everything on the couches and I thought
it broke my neck oh I told the story I
thought it broke my neck once I could
leg like a Swanton bomb is like
it's to pull that off first of all it's
like you have to just trust that your
body's going to land right because
naturally if you if you leave the ground
you're going to freak out you know so
you have to be like it looks like a dive
it looks like an Olympic dive and then
you just got to go all the way and Tuck
and then you got to land with your back
I landed around in my neck and and so to
feel that comfortable yeah did it 100
times the one time that happened nobody
was home I couldn't move my legs I
thought I was dead scary man was like
nine or 10 sorry talking about this
wrestling stuff don't do this at home
for sure um yeah so Stone Cold St you
have to hang out with Stone Cold and
then you go to the events who who are
the big wrestlers now I haven't watched
in Forever uh the the the guy who's
making the most noise is a dude named La
Knight and La Knight Google him he's
he's entertaining really around for a
while and it took him a while to to get
in his you know get in in that vein and
and get the whole crowd pumped up MH
it's very reminiscent of like what the
rock and stone cold would do and get the
crowd to just chant and go back and
forth with you he's really good and a
great wrestler tell me if you
agree I I can't beat the Rock up I don't
think you can beat the Rock up any but
do you think you could Dodge the
people's elbow after the the 30th minute
of him running back and forth do you
think he just left cuz as I watched him
like just get up I think I could have
rolled out I'm pretty sure I could R out
of this one man there's a lot of uh you
know a lot of telegraphing right there
dude I remember the first time I watched
like for real oh elbl him and I was
hooked damn you start watching wrestling
hear you Mo Sasso Hulk St cold
off that's crazy some [__] right there
well that's insane that's a legendary
moment cuz you I mean even though you're
doing stadiums and Arenas there still
like cuz I saw your piece about Arnold
Arnold's my favorite person tery is my
favorite one of my favorite movies ever
um so I have a little story I'll tell
you and I hope you appreciate it because
you like Terminator I was driving
through the hills I just got a new car
you know people like oh nice car I'm
like oh thank you so when I see older
white men they like to stare at my I
used to have a SS mon so it's like the
the NASCAR I have and I have in all
older white men like you know what that
car is like yeah it's it's a lap car I
know 92 people told me today man but oh
man you can't tell them like I'm busy
you have to talk to him for 40 minutes
you can't tell them to go away because
they love your car you have to so I was
pulling up in the hills and I look right
and I see this old man sweeping his
driving he looked just like my grandpa
from the back so I kind of got like that
old like sad like oh man my grandpa and
then he turned around out of nowhere and
it was the
T1000 the actor that plays T1000 for
Terminator 2 Patrick uh yes uh what the
hell is this it's a very easy name and I
can never remember yeah he was in Sons
of Anarchy too exact yeah I can't think
of his name so this was last year and
I'm D I'm staring at him and he whips
around and scares the hell out of me
just the look and I just drove off
immediately I don't know why I look back
like if you startch chasing me I'm going
to [__] start filming this but it was
just incredible to see
look exactly what
happened oh
no you hear it in your head he even
looked scary he even looked at me like
why are you looking at me he looked at
me like like John Conor's my home and he
needs to find him it scared the [__] out
of me I'll just be honest that's pretty
cool though it was kind of cool man I
called my dad immediately dad you'll
never guess what happened that and the
Rambo first Blood me my dad watched 7
million times probably how awesome would
would it have been if back in the day
you know uh people were more open to
collaborations like now right now I
think everybody sees the strength and
and and teaming up with people whereas I
think back then it was like everyone's
out for number one oh for sure like how
badass would it have been to have seen
you know Arnold Schwarzenegger and and
Sylvester Stallone in their Prime do one
movie where they're both playing you
know like the the freaking ultimate cops
or the ultimate guys that go to got to
go save everybody like just one come on
now we got the 70-year-old Expendable
version which is still doable it's still
dope yeah but nobody can do 60 pull-ups
anymore so it's like damn I want you to
see you fall from a tree next to a
helicopter there David goggin you know
what David goggin is no he's the human
Terminator he runs he has the oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah the guy who just like is
is like a like a horse he's just like he
has the most incredible freaking he's
just be big he's the complete opposite
of me but thing is he used to be a big
ass guy he used to be like a husky dude
and then he's like you know I'm going to
start trying to get in shape And The
Fool was running 200 miles now became
the toughest man on Earth on Earth I
believe so I think there's room man what
if what if you never know fluffy 62 is
Arnold rocked out you never know that'd
be kind of cool that would be the only
thing that I have not been able to
accomplish I've never been able to check
that
same so career no problem do you think
that would have a negative impact on
your career if you were to get all
jacked no I think at this point people
just want to see me around you know I'm
at the age now where things become
questionable you're every time I talk to
the doctor you're like well you know
it's like all
right yeah well it can't be easy when
you're traveling every day to work out
dip back problems no you know what you
know what my problem is my biggest
problem is I make excuses I make excuses
for not being in better shape it's it's
a lot easier and that's my that's my
thing I have to work I wish I could and
I wish I could just do this but it's you
know that's that's not the way it works
because it's you're tired and you're
like I have to work I have to work
rather than work out because that's
going to take care of everybody but if I
don't work out I'll put that off to the
side and I'm hungry I didn't eat today I
don't eat that right that's the story of
my life yeah but I mean if I was to lose
like 200 lbs no I I think I'd still be
fine I think I'm funnier than my
appearance there you go dude you lost a
lot of weight though I've yeah I've also
gained a lot of weight so I play that
game all the time it's like okay okay
okay okay like I almost I almost hit 450
at one point and uh the most I lost was
about 110 damn what' you do uh well
that's when I was working I was doing
yoga I was doing DDP Yoga and he was
helping me outp yoga and then you know
having someone call you like he would
call me and he I I swear to God he had
like a a six sense where he knew when I
was in a Drive-Thru I'd be in a
Drive-Thru i' be ordering and my phone
would ring and I'd see his picture and
the name and I'm like oh God and I just
answer I go You Must Have Eyes somewhere
cuz like I'm in a drive I knew it bro I
knew it you just had your location just
keep driving bro just keep driving you
turned his locations on when you're in
the bathroom last time that's what
happened but having accountability
having someone check on you that that's
why he was he was super helpful in
anybody who's thinking about you know
trying something different uh I I
strongly recommend this program it works
if if you stick to it and what's was
that anybody who would buy his program
he would call them and say hey thanks
for buying my program I want to wish you
all the luck and and support and if you
have any questions like you know he he
he's genuinely like invested in his
product and the people that support him
MH that's awesome DD crazy is something
that's awesome yeah he's like 60
something years old big man he can stand
on his face what do you mean I you have
to see it he he'll do push-ups on his
face so he will he's like I want to say
like 6'4 65 he will do a handstand and
then he'll come down and he'll do
push-ups to his
face like a prisoner dude like no
seriously like it it's insane to watch
it almost looks fake it almost looks
like someone's holding his feet and
allowing him to come down and just do
push-ups and stuff like that but I I saw
it myself the guy's he's an animal he's
a machine and he's super flexible he can
grab his foot and hold it up over his
head DP could do this while
standing he almost damn near 70 and so
he's like I could teach you to do that
I'm like no man that looks like a crime
if you get me to do that you you are
yeah you're getting all the secrets I am
not I'm not even trying but anyway he
helped me to lose about 100 pounds and
then Coach though like you have Diamond
Dallas pig as your coach that's kind of
awesome especially if someone growing up
like I love wrestling give me in shape
man imagine yeah and the day that I met
him uh it was I met him at Wrestlemania
and we're like oh my God it's you can we
take a picture he's like yeah and he was
walking to the car he's like can you
guys help me with my with my bags and so
we all carried all of his [__] to the
car and like that was the that was the
fee you carry my [__] you get a picture
hell yeah [__] too come on I read you
were vegan for a year is that when you
lost all the way or no that was a
different time I tried going vegan and
just because you go vegan just cuz you
stop eating MooMoo doesn't mean you're
going to lose weight there's a lot of
fat vegans out there a lot of fat vegans
carbs yeah V for years you have oh dude
cars sorry I wasn't trying to throw
stones I say it's me like it's just
carbs that and like yo it's pasta yeah
it's vegan it's got to be better bro
it's processed soy meat like all right
all right all right I guess [__] and
then I just stopped recently CU I
realized like you can be fat as hell and
vegan still super unhealthy yeah it's
not very unhealthy how about no minerals
and no meat that's basically what my
diet is you know so I did try that and
uh you know I did have certain things
about me like that change definitely
smells was a big component like you know
certain things smell different really
yeah cuz there was no meat involved uh
but I I found myself more irritable and
I found myself not as happy and so I
just I gave it up and it sucks because I
put my girlfriend through it at the time
oh did she hate it or she was down she
was just she was trying to be supportive
of me she knew that I was struggling the
weight thing has always been an issue so
she was just trying to be supportive and
I don't give her enough credit for that
time that she went vegan for me so it's
like I can add that to the list of like
you
know how much does vegan pizza suck I
mean I could eat a cheese pizza that's
fine but I I guess it's like the cheese
is like what Almond or made out of
that's what I'm saying yeah like the
vegan cheese pizzas I just can't find a
being vegetarian and being vegan is to
completely oh yeah well vegetarian you
can still eat eggs and still eat cheese
pizza is like like I kind of care about
the animals kind of yeah that's wasn't
even born yet I just ate the egg just
ate the egg that's that's what happened
to me I don't know if that's what would
be basically yeah I'm vegetarian so I
think so but since he was a kid I just
found out like two years after chilling
with this guy we're at a restaurant go
you don't eat meat but is it for the
reason of animals or just because it's
better for your diet for for you for
your body uh I think it start yeah
probably animals started with just not
really feeling the whole Factory firment
thing and and my mom my parents were hiy
so they put me on to that young age is
just kind of who I am that's different
my parents are not they drug addicts
they're like on McDonald's eat at all I
grew up on W was weenie so yeah I've
been eating meat from day one yep and
then long potatoes The Rusted potatoes
my grand that's the best breakfast in
the world I I miss that and I miss Hot
Pockets it's really not much else I just
love being the little kid running around
like y'all eat the [__] out of a
pepperoni pizza inside this thing uhhuh
I don't know I would just make myself
guess how the is at the house we never
got Hot Pockets here my grandma that was
just my grandma o no Hot Pockets yeah my
grandma was a Jewish white woman so she
was like yo we're not just eating beans
all day like your other Grandma ah [__]
yeah and that's where I discovered Sunny
Delight you discovered what Sunny
Delight and tampo my grandma like T is
this tampo but shinier I'm like no it's
a different b t with a nice label yep
it's the orange stuff it has a
commercial holy [__] I hate Tempo now
too is is basically ghetto Mexican uh
Sunny Delight exactly what it is the red
one though red one that's like rub the
Ruby grapefruit I don't know but it's so
bomb with ice the long ice for my
grandma's so I'm getting all starving
and [__] over here this message is
brought to you by my bookie this entire
season all season long for NFL and
college football they're bringing you a
brand new cash out system with multiple
options to bet and win so if you're
going to be betting online this season
go to mybookie.ag and use our promo code
dope as usual you can register for a
free account and once you do use our
code dope as usual at checkout and
you're going to get one freee chip for
the My Boogie casino and for me to you
it's a free chip if you're going to win
let it ride it was free oh I know if
that's great advice but I've been
betting lately okay so make the free
account once you use your first deposit
use our promo code you're going to get
that free chip to use my Boogie Casino
remember you can bet anything anytime
anywhere using my bookie super contest
free bets odds Booth all season long
with my bookie remember use code dope as
usual and get that free chip for the
casino so make the free account once you
use the first deposit use our promo code
you're going to get that free chip to
use mybookie Casino remember you can pay
anything anytime anywhere using
mybookie.ag super contest free beds odds
Booth all season long with mybookie
remember use code dope as usual and get
that free chip for the casino what's up
guys super stoked and excited to
introduce one of our brand new sponsors
and this is zodic real quick they
dropped off a couple bags for us to try
on this on the show this is the one that
Omar is raving about blue guava is a
cross between gelato 33 and pink guava
so if you're in California and you see
this show and you're like you know what
I want to try that out they're saying
blue guavas like that zodic 420.com that
has a store locator their Instagram
their YouTube every single piece of
information click that store locator
it's going to give you the name of every
single dispensary that carries you know
how we always talk about pheno types
this is the gelato 33 time pink guava
except it's a different feno different
fenos taste different so that's why
these are two different strains
completely so remember guys if it's
going to be on our show you know it's
going to be fire you know it's going to
be Boutique and small badge if you're on
Instagram go to zicore Lifestyle let
them know you saw them on the dope as
usual podcast Z AIX zodic 420.com if
you're at the dispensary and you see the
zodic and you end up getting it tag us
let us know we want to know if you guys
are actually listening if you really
smoking this weed we're really smoking
this weed so thank you so much for being
here and thank you so much for zodic for
sponsoring the show back to the episode
let's let's move on to another topic you
have your own toys sir Funko Pops you
have your own toys that people have't we
posted your coming and I don't know how
many people go I got the Funko Pop yeah
um I started doing merchandise a long
time ago I want to
say probably 15 plus years ago and it
started off with just CDs you know I had
my own CD I recorded my own you know I
hired somebody to come out and record it
for me and then I I found someone who
would package it and put it and make it
look professional and I even had them
put a fake barcode on it just so that it
would look like it's in the stores like
I didn't want it to look hokey yeah you
know I didn't want it to look swap me
the packaging everything was legit and
so once I made that I started selling it
on the road and I just kept reordering
more CDs and just selling those and then
that turned into you know pile of money
that I'm like ooh okay what should I do
and then my Martin was like hey bro you
should sell t-shirts and I'm like why
sell t-shirts the CD cost me 80 cents to
make I turn around I sell it for 20 and
I autograph it at the shows I go look at
the markup on that a t-shirt cost five
bucks and then if I sell it for 20 I'm
only it's like come on man I could you
know he goes bro people want t-shirts
more than they want CDs I go come on and
he introduced me to a guy named memo and
memo became my t-shirt guy and soon as I
started selling T-shirts I'm like oh my
God why haven't I done this sooner and
so the CDs turned into the T-shirt and
then that that became a thing and it's
still a thing with the t-shirts people
still get t-shirts number one somewhere
in there I decided you know what let's
try bobbleheads bobbleheads were really
popular at the time and there was a guy
in uh El Paso Texas named Jim Whidby who
knew a company that made Collectibles
and he helped me make my first
bobblehead and one bobblehead turned
into the two three four I had four
different versions of the bobblehead and
again reinvesting the money and what was
the next thing was an action an action
figure I had an action figure uh made
and I made I had it designed uh to be so
that it would work with the WWE figures
so I wanted it to be the same scale like
my figure could hold the chair my figure
could stand in the ring and be the same
height as the other wrestlers and so I
sold that one for a while and then the
next thing after that was
uh God I want to say Funko uh we had
contacted Funko to see if they were
interested in having a Comics line of
funkos and they're like well out we know
who you are but that doesn't fit our
thing and I'm like what do you mean it
doesn't fit your thing you guys have
YouTubers you guys have you know uh
athletes and and movie stars and TV
stars and all kinds of different popular
people Comics are popular yeah and they
were not interested and so we tried
again two years later and they said well
we're still not interested in licensing
however we will produce it for you uh
but you have to there's a minimum order
and I think they were trying to get rid
of me cuz the order that they threw at
me was stupid
it was it was a lot and so next thing
you know a semi truck shows up at my
building full of funkos and we sold them
in in about two months all of them gone
and most of them online wow and so we
ordered more and they're like wait what
sold out and then so we did a reorder
and those sold out and then they said
well do you want to do a second one sure
and we did a second one and that sucker
killed and then we ordered more and then
that sold out and then they're like do
you want to do another one sure and so
it started I got the number one Funko
Pop the number two Funko Pop and then I
think Joe Koy jumped in there we got the
same manager so I think he made a call
he saw what what I was doing on that one
and uh and Jeff Dunham as well Jeff
Dunham jumped in there and so and then
next thing you know we started selling
those out and then I just started
getting the next one let's come out with
the next one let's come out with the
next one and now there's like God about
15 oh there's some there's some that
haven't even been released yet and so
there's they're still waiting and I'm
just you know I'll be releasing those
for at least another couple years is it
odd seeing yourself as a toy uh like in
the cool I've always seen myself as a
toy you know what I'm saying though no
it's it is really cool it is really
really cool and it's nice to know that
you know parts of me are out there
sitting on you know shelves and stuff
like that and that's really really cool
that people would want that as far as
your fan base and like who's buying the
stuff would you can you even nail it
down is it the parents or is it the kids
on Tik Tok or you know what I mean the
people that have been watching you for
all these years or but you have this
whole younger gener generation of fans
too I think the first the first go round
was um very much uh collectors and
people that resell collectors and
resellers I think that first time out
because it's like whoa he's the first
comedian it's the number one and so
anytime you can get your hands on first
generation anything you know that
there's going to be value to it later so
I think that's what helped in the
beginning was the the the resellers and
the collectors and my fans were third on
that one but by the time that I think
the third figure came out it's it's
completely flipped so the majority of
the Funko pops are are are my fans that
that want them nice that's awesome you
know but there's still resellers out
there there oh there are yeah go on eBay
it's like oh God all right and it's one
that you signed randomly one day and
it's quadruple and so sometimes I'll see
people at shows and they're they're
holding them and you could tell which
ones are the fans and which ones are
like resellers M you know and he like
and then uh what I'll do is they say hey
okay I'll sign it who do I make it out
to no just just sign
it that's when you find let me
personalize it for you man I want to
make sure that it's no no that's cool
just just just sign it damn I never even
thought about that what a good way to
catch somebody yeah who do I make it out
to who do I make it out
to yeah but then sometimes you'll get
those that are like okay to Carlos and
to David and Sochi and I'm like bro I
can I can't fit all those names on there
just just put them on there like damn
dude like I I people ask me to sign
their vape pens a lot and it's this big
dude good luck with that sucks it just
looks like a smear on everybody's like
that's Thomas uhhuh I feel you so you
have your own toy I have a question cuz
after the toy I have a question ask you
should make like a card a card like a
baseball card no yeah like a baseball
card and something that you can actually
sign on I had one once but it was only
one it was me with a a joint like this
and it was like the Little League
baseball thing I put like fire in the
back you know like the old Nolan Ryan
cards when you were you were a kid it
looked like that but it was like it was
a parody but that would be fun um I
asked every single guest this you've
been doing comedy you said over 20
years there's got to I me I get it you
made a room of your homies laugh you
made your whole family laugh and then
you do it in front of a stage I I mean
that first time I'm assuming you know
you're getting up there but when's the
first time you got comfortable went home
and went you're going to crush this cuz
we always have that moment of like I can
do this and we ask every athlete Comm
meet doesn't matter who it is there's
always that one moment you went home
like what this is real do you remember
that I never went home and and and tried
to get that uh laugh from anybody like
that was never a thing for me cuz I I
always felt like my family would would
find a way to see through it or not not
understand it or look at it the same way
like a like a fan would at a show oh um
I'm never trying to to practice material
amongst family oh no I or friends like
that but I even back then once I started
doing it there was never that that thing
it was when I finally hit a stage and
got the laughs in the room when it was
when it counted yes cuz normally off
stage I'm I'm very quiet I'm not I'm not
trying to be the loudest one I'm
actually a really really good listener
uh and so I'd rather just okay when the
time comes and you got to hit the button
and grab the mic and now like okay do
right thing you Superman puts on the
cape but I I meant in the terms of like
you make your whole family crack up as a
kid oh wow I'm kind of funny or whatever
it is I'm saying no never I'm what's the
moment like you went home after the
stage I met and you went oh my God I wow
I was already grown up and out of the
house by then you got to figure I didn't
stand up until me even your apartment I
meant like you go home you're the it's
just you you're turning the lights up
you're going to sleep like I did a great
job tonight at the set oh my God I think
I can do this it for me that's what I me
this is it what's I need to think of a a
slogan for this question this is it I
can do it the real
when did you know no April 10th 1997
that was the first day I went up on
stage once I I did the set I went home
that night and I was like laying there
in bed and I'm like okay that's that
first step so like whenever I get the
question of what's what's been the
greatest you know moment in your career
well there's a lot of Great Moments you
know and clearly the Dodger Stadium one
is like that's the peak but Dodger
Stadium doesn't happen if I don't get on
that small stage April 10 1997 so that
first step of actually doing it getting
that click click and now we're off if I
would have gotten cold feet and not gone
up on that stage I'd still be selling
cell
phones all the laughs that wouldn't have
happened yeah think about it if you were
too scared to go out and do it it's a
good message right there that's awesome
no and and most definitely always bet on
yourself um I did not get into a comedy
club it took me forever to get to get
into a comedy club I had to just do
holes in the wall little shows uh bar
shows uh Comics would create their own
rooms you know to have comedy nights
like at you know whatever Bar and Grill
oh they got a little showroom or
whatever by the bar they got 40 seats
then we do shows little tiny shows like
that and the most non-conducive
environments you know you walk into a
comedy club people are facing you
there's a stage or up high there's a
microphone there's good sound lighting
they're focused on you there's no
distractions that's awesome but when I
first started doing standup it's man
people clinking cups and and glass just
falling on the ground and people are
loud the the Laker game is on TV people
you know you're you're there's a lot of
distractions and so I had to learn to be
funny with distractions which I think
just made me stronger because then once
I got to a comedy club where it's like
wow they're they're pay paying attention
they're looking at me I don't got yeah
this is this is awesome this is really
cool here for this not just at the bar
totally get it but I had to do a lot of
shows like you know I had to create my
own opportunity that's what I'm trying
to say you know I didn't you know you
you can't just wait if it's not coming
to you you stop waiting do something
about it and now more than ever there's
so many tools there's so many just and
they're free social Med a lot of people
see social media is bad but man if you
use it the right way you can you know
you can make an incredible living you
can follow your dreams you know and you
got the tools you don't got to wait for
Hollywood and you did that before
Myspace and Facebook and all this stuff
so yeah you kind of have to be out like
you with the mixtape I got to sell my
tapes I can't just put it on Facebook
and what sets you apart from all the
other comedians are like the you know I
read you're one of the top paid
comedians on Earth right now what sets
you apart to me when I watch your act it
hits more like watching a movie it's
like it's almost like we said a TED talk
like a tour guide around this joke like
you you have this trust with your
audience that it's like I'm not just
slanging jokes to make you laugh but I'm
on this ride around this thought and
we're coming back and it it just feels
different and I know that you said like
like I I only talk about things that are
relatable to everybody I don't talk
about religion and politics and is there
any advice that you might be able to
give to younger people that are thinking
about putting themselves out and making
content making videos about just what
separated you and from everybody else in
your class and the things you chose to
put out there well first of all you need
to ask yourself is this going to be for
fun is it a hobby or do I want to make a
career out of it because you'll approach
it differently you know and then you
have to uh ask yourself okay well what
is it that I want to convey what what
message and what type of humor do I want
to put out there because depending on
the type of humor you want to put out
there is is how many people you're going
to be able to get invested in what it is
that you do so if you're really
political only people that want to hear
political humor are going to be into it
because most of the time people don't
want to hear that they're wrong or that
they're thinking wrong or that their way
of life is wrong and polit political
humor that's all it is true you know
what side are you want and if you're if
you're not on that side and you're
listening to the wrong show then you're
going to feel like oh man you know or
sometimes uh people don't want to hear
an hour of cussing a lot of people don't
like cussing okay so uh are you going to
be the person that cusses or the person
that doesn't cuss or if you do cuss is
it just minimal where it's enough to
prove a point but not be the whole thing
cuz in the beginning I was filthy I was
cussing I was dropping F bombs every
other yes a lot of people don't know
that I was a very dirty comic when I
first started remember keep in mind the
environment that I was performing in I
was performing at bars dive bars it was
Hood I was in montabello across the
street from the hospital which was very
convenient cuz people were getting
shanked all the time you know so you're
like he's going to bleed out now just
cross hit the button cross the light
right there go er um so yeah I was very
dirty and a comic by the name of Joy
Medina pulled me aside and he goes dude
man you're very likable you're very
funny stop cussing if you stop cussing
you're just going to open the door for
yourself and and more opportunities are
going to be available to you and that
was the best advice I ever got now don't
get me wrong I cuss now but it's
different it's again it's not the whole
show I'll drop a couple things here and
there I'm a 47y old bald dude now so
it's I kind of earned it a little bit
you know uh but know what it is that you
want to talk about I knew early on that
I had this gift to make people laugh I
knew that the characters and the sound
effects and the voices I needed to find
a way to magnify that but also be true
to myself so once I started telling
stories I just combined the characters
the voices along with the stories and
that's why you would hear this long ride
and I learned that that was my gift my
gift wasn't setup punch I can't do setup
punch so people say write me some jokes
or how come you're not on a roast I
don't do that I'm not that's not my
thing yeah I tell stories and sometimes
on paper they're not that good but it's
you know the performance of it is what
sells it because a lot of my stuff you
look it on paper you're like I don't
know man he just keeps saying Martin
what's up what's so funny about that he
says it again Martin what is Ora or o
what is oral
yeah you know what I mean but uh know
what it is that you want to do uh and
then you know don't wait for people to
to bring stuff to you you need to go out
there and find it MH uh it's harder to
give advice now because the world has
changed so much and my advice is coming
from a 47-year-old who's already you
know who started off handing out flyers
yeah on car putting a car windows
actually talking to people going on a
radio station and you know like all
right man come and see me this weekend
I'll be at the ice house and it's going
to be great and da d d d whereas now you
just send out a post you know what I
mean so it's it's very different and
it's it's harder to give the advice but
I can just say that if it's something
you want to do be ready to sacrifice
sacrifice is the biggest thing what are
you willing to give up in order to get
to where you want to be because once
people start making money you get
comfortable and you're like no this is
good I got to hold on to this but then
are you growing or is that as far as
you're going to get mhm you know there
was a lot of shows that I had to do
where I made no money but the whole idea
was we got to break that market got we
got to break that market we got to go in
and introduce ourselves let the people
know what we do let them check it out
and then hope that they tell a friend so
next time we we come back we can play
that so when you see the map of the US
that original map was just LA and I was
only performing there in LA and then I
had eventually oh San Diego oh and then
Fresno oh Bakersville okay you know and
then it just started growing and then we
had to take chances and go out and break
markets Las Vegas I couldn't sell
tickets in Las Vegas to save my life in
the beginning it took a long time and
then once we did then it was like okay
you break the market and some places
like Vegas is like you got to rely on
the tourist M so to be able to actually
get the people that live in the city to
come out to see your show that's a huge
one because it's like used to it they
have but they have so much so many
options you know why go see the comic
you can go see the guys that freaking
take on the tigers or the magician that
you know falls from the ceiling or the
guy that you know there's so many things
you can go see shoot you can stand in
front of the Bellagio and just look at
water and it's free and you're like oh
my God this is
nice so it's it's the foundation that
you did for all those years that's
really paying off now sacrifice
sacrifice give up the parties give up
the the be ready to give up a lot of
relationships because there's going to
be a lot of people that are that you
trust and you love and you want to
listen but their advice isn't based on
your passion your passion is going to
see one thing and they're only going to
see another you know people that get
into certain positions it's because they
had that passion that drive and that
want and I'm sure that everybody told
them I don't know man you better be
careful you know you got a good thing
going on over here this and that and so
you got to be willing to trust yourself
and yes there's good advice out there
like I said that one comic Joy Medina
and it's funny cuz he's filthy he's
dirty dirty as [__] he does a lot of
dirty he's one that told you to stop
he's the one that told me to stop it but
he saw something he he saw something I
didn't so yeah but be willing to
sacrifice all those great I miss so many
like Christmas shows and uh or birthdays
and just being gone I was always on the
road I just wanted to say yes to
everything cuz it's an opportunity and I
just had that that mindset like you
know there's work you got to go work so
what's next God I guess trying to lose
weight
bro 6 all the shows I mean I'm I'm still
out there grinding and uh you know I I
don't want to assume that that it's just
you know coasting I still got to go out
and put in the work otherwise it's going
to go away MH you know I always feel
like you got to protect your job you got
to make sure you go out there and keep
working you to have you way champ walk
around with the B CU here's here's other
people coming here's other people coming
and and don't get me wrong I I think
it's great that that there's more people
out we need more laughter and I'm happy
to support and help you know the the
Next Generation if they want it I'm not
going to just be like hey you got to
listen and this is how it is yeah I
don't want to be that dude either you're
here doing this that's an example of it
so but uh yeah we appreciate that yeah
could have had better water then I'm
kiding what is this mountain I just bom
love that water yeah no it looks legit
dude in this bottle that's our fav crack
somebody with it that's a weapon uh
question I saw your ggn and I saw you
smoke with the Snoop Dog yes I did how
was that I know everybody ask like you
smok 60 Bloods probably not but how was
the experience of there's not many
people that get the opportunity that you
got and to be on ggn doing it at the
same time kind of a legendary moment
that I always see on internet you know
um I had a a run from my mid 20s I think
maybe a good three years where I was
smoking every day I was smoking all the
time um I had bought a I had bought a uh
a bong from Tommy Chong Nice and when I
was in Florida I went to one of his
comedy shows and he used to have these
bongs and I bought one and he
autographed it and I and I remember when
he autographed it I told him I said man
you know I says I said I am never using
this this is going to go up on my shelf
he you got to use it man better smoke
that signature off of
there and I was like I was like
impression I was like okay and next
thing I know man I started I my goal was
to smoke the autograph off the signature
and it will eventually and I did I did
uh but yeah no I had I run about 3 years
so I was very amiliar with with smoking
and I was I was cool with I just it
didn't you know I I it was a phase in my
life I enjoyed it it was cool and I'm
good uh but if Snoop Dogg invites you to
go on his show and Snoop hands you uh uh
you know something yes you participate
you are in you you got to know going in
that this is how it's going to go and it
was awesome I had my son with me you
know he had a great time and it was
funny that afterwards he wanted to like
you know cuz there was a still piece of
the joint left
and you know he wanted to take a hit
with with Snoop how old's your son God
he's 26 now oh okay so when you say
sound like a no it was like God so my
four-year-old no no he's he's a dude
he's already a dude he's a dude he's a
dude dude but no it was it was really
cool but let me tell you the strength of
what Snoop has it's yeah that's I don't
know where they make that I don't know
how it's cultivated or whatever but yeah
I've I've got I got to smoke with him
twice once on that show and at
WrestleMania so WrestleMania they asked
me to WWE asked me to go and and do
interviews and stuff and just promotion
like social media that's my thing so I'm
like bouncing around and then they asked
that I go on snoop's bus and interview
him and talk to him about WrestleMania
because he was like part of the main
event for the first night and so a
camera crew followed me on the snoop's
bus we get on there and he's there like
hey what it do baby boo how you feel you
know just give me a hug and hey and
right off the bat he sees the cameras
and he's a pro as soon as he saw the
cameras he presents me with a present he
goes here this for you and he hands me a
little backpack that has snoop's face on
it I'm like oh this is sick and then he
pulls out this box this red box and it's
his death row on the box and he's like
open that sick and I opened it up and
it's his big freaking death row chain
giant chain and then he just took it out
of the box and he goes turn around and
he starts putting it on me and it's like
you know I see it he he puts it like
he's nighing me right and so he puts it
around my neck and then he's pulling it
up to to to to fasten it right but when
he's pulling it up I realized like oh
[__] like I have a big [__] neck so
by the time by the time he was able to
click it it was already like like choker
yeah yeah I was about to be I almost
became the guy in the chair cuz he
pulled it up so high and then I heard
the click click and I'm like oh God
thank you I didn't think it was going to
click and I heard him he goes That's
what I
said but anyway uh so he put that on me
in the camera and big old like heyy yeah
don't miss Snoop this weekend blah blah
blah WrestleMania be your main event and
then the guys are like thanks a lot
Snoop thanks FL and then they got off
the bus and as soon as they got off the
bus and you heard the door closed clck
Snoop goes I didn't think they'd ever
leave and then here we go I'm like oh my
God round two and you don't say no no
you can't you don't say no can't say and
so by the time I got off that bus WWE
wanted me to go do another interview and
I said do you understand I just got off
of snoop's bus and you want me to go be
productive right now do you see my eyes
I was eating cereal on his bus Dry
Cereal yeah I was e dral you are you
start cring Dry Cereal and by the way
you think I have merchandise Snoop has
everything Snoop has his own weed he's
got his own chains he's got his own
cereal so he's like here have like Snoop
right and I'm like eating I'm like am I
high or is this this is crazy he's got
his own cereal so I was eating dried
cereal out the bag
just and he kept looking at me you good
I'm like I'm good I'm good and he had
other he had other people on the bus and
I'm just watching the people and I'm
just like gone and I got my chain you
The Medallion seriously like it's like
this big it's huge you kept it oh he
gave it that was for you he gave it to
me I thought he like yo the camera put
this on I'm going to see if I could try
to find cuz man it was such an awesome
experience this was uh in April April
April April and then um but yeah the uh
here we go
oh it's getting real it's getting real
getting closer getting
closer getting closer cuz it was the
first night damn WrestleMania dude we
got to go Marty that sounds so fun that
would be sick there is no Undertaker but
still you know and that was always
something that I would look forward to
every year was that you know the
undertakers the streak you know we keep
that streak going God he's so cool man
he's so bad Undertaker just went on
another podcast I saw him talk for the
first time it's like
voice yeah it's like uh he used to be in
WCW he was mean Mark Callas oh you've
been watching for forever do you
remember the dudle boys yes yeah they
were wild I can't find the picture but
it's it's it's onl you probably find it
on my Instagram ew was crazy that was
crazy with the chairs and the fire thumb
tacks they were talking [__] to the
audience remember when they used to do
that oh ohw they they will annihilate
you and you're just paid to be there oh
they cuss you out like you're in their
backyard thank you he got on a mom I was
like oh my God am I allowed to watch
this and my grandma wasn't home so I
watched it um so yeah so anyway long
story short yeah Snoop two times
incredible both times I felt like uh
someone took my head like an eter sketch
and just did this now go function and
I'm just like sitting there just like
wow I remember eating a muffin cuz they
put us in a suite and someone had me a
muffin and I just like I just like I
felt like licking the muffin and I
remember like that muffin was so good
uh-huh it was probably just a basic
[__] muffin but probably some Costco
well Costco no Costco CostCo muffins
yeah to take a back instantly I can't
those blueberry ones full I'm addicted
um so the reason I brought it up cuz I I
wasn't sure in know
your team told us he's got a DTI dis
appointment he can't be getting high as
hell today so I understand that's why
we're rare we don't we don't like to
smoke people out but I did roll this in
case you did smoke you have to smoke it
but I rolled this oh God what is that
it's a fluffy joint I rolled this cuz I
was like cuz usually we're like we're
like right here and I'm like no he's
going to come I want to roll am I going
to smoke that or smuggle it cuz you know
what's funny I I rolled something like
this for cheich one time like eight
years ago I was like yo you want to
smoke this I didn't say that I walked up
to him like Hey I rolled this man he
goes thanks so much man it's going to be
great tonight he walked off I was like
oh [__] should have made it clear that
hey you want to smoke this with me he
like this going to be great tonight oh
yeah he didn't include you in the party
it was it was awesome though like you
know like you're going to go home and
that so that's mine yeah that's you dude
do I do I need like one of those meth
blow torches to freaking light it uh no
you don't cuz it's like oh this little
short one this a little torch but yeah I
know you have to go to the dentist so I
was like yeah you could just take that
home dude there's like four different
types of very very good weed in there
wow yeah you can take that home if you
don't want to smoke it's a little I
don't even know how you how you roll
this that's like this like a burrito and
then yeah know you went straight
Chipotle on this thing huh that's
exactly what I said yeah you you went
full chipot on this when he was filming
it
exact but yeah I know you have to go to
dentist I don't want to smoke you out
and get you too damn High next time yeah
next time they United the dentist but
that wow take that take that home no
problem all some other stuff for him too
oh yeah I do have some other stuff for
you but before we do that um your tour
is for the next couple years so where
can people get tickets now uh Google the
word fluffy that's it just Google the
word fluffy I would say it's
fluffyguy.com you can go to the site but
I mean if you just Google it's fun
because I'm the number one thing that
pops up so people say how do I find you
branding that's another thing branding
work on your branding uh yeah the word
FL I I basically own it so it doesn't
matter what search engine you use if you
just Google or whatever the thing is
just punch and fluffy I will P come up
before cats quilts comforters cotton
candy um you know anything fluffy wow I
love I'm I'm the number one fluffy you
just name off many fluffy things in
thead I would yes if this is a if this
is a family feud I I challenge anybody
you're just just take two seconds Google
the word and see what happens and if I'm
lying hey whatever that's some confident
SEO right there yeah it is huh that's 15
years of building right there that's
awesome and that and that was early on
that was early on that I started working
on that the nickname I don't know where
oh the nickname came from a joke I did a
joke one night where I said you know
talking about that I wasn't fat I was
Fluffy and then after the show was over
no one came up to me and said hey good
job Gabriel or hey elas come here
everybody kept calling me fluffy so it
became it was very it was very organic
um um that people started calling me
that I'm like I have a name you know and
I was getting annoyed that people were
doing that but I didn't want to give up
the joke because I felt like it was a
strong bit and so it became one of those
things where eventually I learned to
embrace the word fluffy and then I just
hit the gas with it and just everything
was branded fluffy so the company so you
know fluffy shop Studios fluffy Inc you
know and then making it a point every
single special I put out had the word in
it so like the first one you know hot
and fluff second one I'm Not Fat I'm
Fluffy third one Aloha fluffy next
Fluffy Movie you know smart this is [__]
they teach you in college those came out
when I was in seventh grade so nobody
just Hey fat kid like I'm Fluffy I
didn't have that other word to call
myself man I wish I had that as a kid oh
then I had I had bits back in the day
where I talk about how uh you you're
limited on what you can wear because
they associate you with something so
like I couldn't Wear Yellow it's like
hey Pac-Man it's Pikachu you know you
can't wear red hey Kool-Aid you know
worst dude I wore red shirt every color
equaled something I was like oh God all
right my orange shirt look like the sun
that's what everybody told me like all
right full I wear black every day again
forever forever I wore brown last week
and I was like oh the ball from Indiana
Jones I'm like you're a dick I made that
one up but that's what I felt like so I
feel you I have the same I have the same
ailments I guess you would call I get it
enjoy your hair yo my grandpa's 855 with
a head of hair so I'm really looking
forward
think I'm going to be okay my mom had
really thin hair and her dad was was
bald so I I knew this was going to
happen damn it's over and I'm like it
was a good run it was a good run hey man
sometimes you don't got to wake up and
do this like you know what sometimes
it's better just walk out the door mhm
but man I just really wanted to thank
you for being here because I know you
have a heart out for that dentist and um
thank you for being here thank you for
taking the time to come here we've been
hyped we've been stoked our fans are
stoked everyone's excited man my family
is texting me my
you're a it's a universal laughter man
was there was there somebody in the
family that was really trying to watch
this or wanted to you know oh my mom
yeah yeah my sister there you go oh your
sister yeah sister what's her name Jess
her name's Justin
Jessica Jessica Jessica okay I thought
you said Justin I'm like okay you know
it's 2023 man it's a it's it's a
different time totally normal you Dia
Dia Justin yeah Justin Jessica right
yeah Jessica Jessica Hi how are you this
is gabrielas I wanted to say hello sorry
you're not here clearly they don't love
you enough to bring you but that's okay
I love you I care about you and I hope
you have a wonderful wonderful day uh
yeah this don't
ask yeah it's yeah it's it's yeah
El oh man thank you so much for being
here dude really appreciate this was fun
thank you for taking the time thank sir
we really appreciate fluffy guy fluffy
on Google just Google fluffy any tickets
for for the next couple years you're a
monster you're awesome and I hope I have
the confidence to fly like you one day
thank you next
week off to the dentist yeah thank you
so much for being here guys this has
been the dope as usual podcast for Marty
fluffy and I have a dope ass day yeah
bless you bless you perfect time 2:30 on
the
[Music]
dot
perfect
[Music]